[Aplausos]
nosotros los estados unidos de américa
estamos del lado del pueblo ucraniano
durante nuestra historia hemos aprendido
esta lección cuando los dictadores no
pagar un precio por su agresión causan
mucho más caos siguen avanzando y el
costo de las amenazas a eeuu y al resto
del mundo sigue aumentando por eso es
que la alianza de la otan fue creada
para asegurar la paz y la estabilidad en
europa tras la segunda guerra mundial
los eeuu es un miembro junto con otras
29 naciones y eso importa
la diplomacia estadounidense importa la
determinación estadounidense importa el
último ataque de putin sobre ucrania fue
premeditado y totalmente no provocado el
rechazo reiterada de los esfuerzos de
información él pensó que el occidente y
que la otan no responderían él pensó que
podía dividirnos en casa en esta cámara
en esta nación él pensó que podía
dividirnos en europa también pero putin
estaba equivocado nosotros estamos
listos y estamos unidos
eso fue lo que hicimos permanecimos
unidos nos preparamos con mucho cuidado
pasamos meses construyendo colisiones
con otras naciones amantes de la
libertad también el continente americano
africano para confrontar a putin con
muchos de ustedes he pasado muchas horas
tratando de unificar a nuestros aliados
europeos
compartimos con el mundo con
anticipación lo que sabíamos que putin
estaba planeando
y les dijimos cómo iba a tratar de
falsificar y justificar su agresión
nosotros contrarrestamos las mentiras
rusas con la verdad y ahora ahora que ha
actuado
el mundo libre es haciendo que sea
responsable junto con otros 27 miembros
de la unión europea incluyendo a francia
alemania italia así como países como el
reino unido canadá japón corea australia
nueva zelanda y muchos otros incluida
suiza
están causándole daños a rusia y está
respaldando al pueblo ucraniano putin
ahora está aislado del mundo mucho más
de lo que nunca había estado